بلباس نساء وعمال نظافه اقتحمت وحدات من
المستعربين البلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس
تلاها رطل من الاليات العسكريه التي
اقتحمت المدينه
واطلقت النيران وقنابل الغاز باتجاه
الطلبه
القوات الاسرائيليه حاصرت ام منزلا داخل
حاره الياسمين
واستخدمت صواريخ ورصاصا متفجرا
بعد رفض المقاومين الاستسلام
الاعداد الكبيره للجنود الاحتلال شفناها
كانت معبيه الحاره
وماخذين نقاط بجميع الدور اللي حوالين
الحاره طبعا عشان هذا اسلوبهم لا يعرفوا
ما حداش يقدر يخرج من الحاره
وصوتي التفجيرات بشكل مش طبيعي يعني ما
اهمهم انه في صغار في مرضعه في في حريم فش
عندهم حرمات
معاذ مصري وحسن قطناني وابراهيم جوري صاحب
المنزل اغتالتهم قوات الاحتلال بعد شهر من
تنفيذ عمليه في الاغوار ادت الى مقتل ثلاث
مستوطنات
تشييع الشهداء شارك فيه الاف الفلسطينيين
تقدمهم عشرات المقاومين من الفصائل كافه
كتائب القسام الجناح المسلح لحركه حماس
نعت الشهداء وقالت ان العمليه نفذت في
الاغوار ردا على تدنيس المسجد الاقصى
واستهداف المعتكات في شهر رمضان
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه حملت الاحتلال
التداعيات عمليه الاغتيال بينما توعدت
الفصائل بالانتقام عمليه الاغتيال تاتي في
ظل التهديدات الاسرائيليه بتوسيع العمليات
العسكريه في شمال الضفه الغربيه والتي لا
يستثنى منها الاسرى وهذه المشاهد لحجم
الدمار والاعلان الفوري عن تفاصيل العمليه
تبدو وفق مراقبين رساله لارضاء منتقدي
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
فحجم الدمار الذي ظهر بعد تنفيذ العمليه
اشار وفق مراقبينا الى انها توجه رساله
للداخل الاسرائيلي في محاوله لكسر اراده
الشعب الفلسطيني على المقاومه واستعاده
هيبه الردع الاسرائيليه التي تضررت كثيرا
في الاشهر الاخيره لذلك علينا ان نستعد
لمعركه كبيره
لكن نهار محافظتي نابلس لم ينتهي فجنود
الاحتلال قتلوا الشابه ايمان عوده في بلده
حوار الجنوبيه المحافظه حيث زعم الاحتلال
انها حاولت طعن جندي بينما فند
الفلسطينيون هذه الروايه
الجزيره نابلس